we just got some groundbreaking brand
new leaks and rumors concerning the mac
pro coming at wwdc and as you know if
you've been following this channel i
have been making a couple of videos
talking about this year's mac pro and
how apple can make a new quad die chip
happen yes not two dies like in the m1
ultra but four dies combined together
for basically the fastest consumer
computer out there right now destroying
nvidia amd intel all of them because
this ship is going to be insane and the
reason that both of these videos are
called m2 is because of somebody named
hector martin yes this is his page right
here and he is actually in charge of
porting linux to the apple silicon max
with asahi linux and he is doing such a
great job at it and he told us for a
while now that it is totally impossible
to make a four die chip while using the
m1 max dies and the reason i believe
that that was coming was based on a leak
from mark german last year as you can
see right here in october he said that
the new mac pro chip would have either a
two times or four times m1 max die
configuration so the two times is
actually the m1 ultra and the four times
is supposed to be the m1 ultra duo or
the m1 extreme but unfortunately hector
martin replied to my tweets and he said
that the irq controller in each die can
only handle two dies so he basically
said that it is impossible and right
here you could actually see hector
martin saying that a four times l1 max
chip which is what that bloomberg guy
said who is mark kerman and everybody
else has been repeating is not
possible so he says four m1 max dies
together is not possible but
wait a second because
very recently
literally march 30th he completely
flipped the script and you can see my
tweet right here talking about how he
does in fact believe that it could be
possible and as you can see he was
actually quote tweeting a leak from
imagine boo showing new ultra fusion
connections and interposers and a new
layout and check this out he said this
is interesting i still think a four die
apple silicon system is much more likely
to use a new die and if this is really
using unmodified m1 max dies then it's a
really weird retrofit and not
symmetrical across the halves and he
goes on to explain that the irq
controllers and the m1 max can only
handle two dies but he mentions the
possibility of apple using two irq
controllers in two of those dies but the
big point i want to make is that hector
martin was literally the only reason why
i believed it would be coming with the
m2 extreme or m2 ultra duo because he
said m1 max dies would not be possible
but now that he changes mind everything
finally is making sense for example
imagine boos leak showed that there's
going to be a new mac pro in 2022 coming
this september yes this september and he
says that the bridge is going to be
connecting two m1 ultra dies together
not m2 ultra m1 ultradice together and
with that said there are a lot of other
sources who believe the mac pro still
has to come this year for example mark
german back in december said that we
should be expecting a revamped mac pro
with apple silicon in 2022
and the craziest thing was back in
january mark said that he believes the
apple silicon transition will be
completed by june and wwdc
and he even clarified he said i don't
believe the mac pro will be released at
wwdc rather announced so mark fully
believes that the mac pro is being
announced at
wwdc but it doesn't stop there we have
leaks apple pro who came out with a
product roadmap and for 2022
he once again mentioned that the mac pro
is coming alongside a new 27-inch mini
led display with pro motion tech and the
craziest thing is he said it's going to
be announced at wwc but going even
further we have of course the source
ross young who is extremely accurate in
terms of display leaks he mentioned that
the 27 inch mini led display is coming
in june yes in june so i asked him if
it's going to be coming alongside a new
mac pro and he said yes that is our
thinking and he once again confirmed
that it's going to be launching in june
with the mac pro and that totally makes
sense because if there is a new high-end
display launching at wwdc it absolutely
needs to launch alongside a high-end mac
and this perfectly lines up with apple's
march event when they showed off the mac
studio when they mentioned we have one
more mac to release which is of course
the mac pro so revealing it at wwdc
would make perfect sense because they
would be able to brag that they fully
closed out their apple silicon
transition and shipped or revealed the
mac pro however there is a little
problem when apple revealed the m1 ultra
chip at the event they said that there
was one last chip going into the m1
processor family which was of course the
m1 ultra so a lot of people are saying
there's no way we're getting an m1x
stream or anything like that which means
that the mac pro is not coming this year
it has to come later because we can't
get another chip in the lineup but we
just got some brand new leaks there is a
guy named bob he's a new source he is
not that credible but everything that
he's been saying makes sense to me so
take it with a great assault but i
actually trust in what he has to say so
on march 31st he said the chip coming in
the new mac pro will not be part of the
m1 or the m2 family yes that means that
apple is likely to give it a brand new
name so for example x1 or z1 or x1 duo a
brand new family of chips just like
intel has their regular core i9s and
then they have their xeons and the
important thing about that is that if
you give it a different name like x1 it
is kind of separated from the consumer
lineup of chips so if the mac pro
doesn't get updated for let's say three
to four years it doesn't feel like
they're releasing newer m2 m3 m4 chips
that are better than the mac pro chips
because it has a different x1 name so
it's in a different league so that
totally makes sense to me so if apple
does give it a brand new unique name
that means they were not lying when they
said that the m1 ultra is the last chip
in the m1 family because this one's
gonna be brand new and with that said
bob actually agreed that introduction
this summer is still possible and he
went on to say that the mac pro will be
at wwdc
but guess what leak he just put out this
one is a little bit shocking to me he
says the m2 chip is not coming at wwdc
but then bob gave us an even crazier
leak that kind of puts everything into
perspective and wraps it all up he says
that he knows for sure that after wwdc
the intel mac pro and the mac mini intel
model will be gone yes discontinued
now that is something crazy because i
was personally expecting apple to keep
the intel mac pro around maybe for
another year as the transition gets
wrapped up just for the people who need
things like 1.5 terabytes of ram or for
those high-end amd cards but he is
saying that they're completely
discontinuing the rest of the intel
models which would basically mean that
apple would completely finish the apple
silicon transition within the two-year
timeline since the wwdc of 2020 and that
would be kind of like bragging rights
for apple and the craziest thing is that
this perfectly matches up to what mark
german said saying that the transition
is going to be wrapped up and completed
by wwdc
2022 getting rid of all the intel chips
so bob and mark are on the same page but
now that i've went through all of those
sources agreeing that the mac pro is
coming this year at wwdc and it's not
going to be based on the m2 it's going
to be based on the m1 max with a new
product name
it's time to go through how i personally
expect apple to put the mac pro together
including the chassis the size of it
what's going to be inside of it how much
ram if there's going to be graphics
options so let's get into that first of
all mark german from bloomberg gave us a
new article on march 13th talking about
the mac pro and how apple can pull it
off and mark gave us two possibilities
the simplest explanation is that apple
could roll out a mac pro with an m1
ultra as well as a dual m1 ultra without
giving that higher power chip a new name
so apple was not lying the m1 ultra is
the best chip they're just putting two
of them into the mac pro so that is one
option and then the second option was
for apple to hold off on the new mac pro
until the m2 ultra and dual m2 ultra are
ready so i think that is not likely
based on everything that we discussed in
this video i believe apple is just going
to be giving us the m1 ultra duo with
potentially a new x1 or whatever name
and in terms of how they would do that
my first idea was for them to stack to
on top of each other but that might not
be likely because you've got to deal
with heat and it makes things a little
bit more complicated so this brings me
back to what hector martin said about
majin buu's leak and here you can see
there's three ultra fusions and if you
see this little image right in the
corner you can see that they're
combining
two m1 ultras together which he
confirmed with a new ultra fusion going
down the middle somehow combining them
potentially on different layers
combining them together but the craziest
thing is that imagine boo confirmed that
apple is going to be able to put in a
form of ultra fusion which can access a
separate memory controller along with
on-chip controllers to access up to one
terabyte of memory yes that means that
with apple silicon apple is going to be
able to
take the mac pro chip the quad die chip
and connect it to external ram module
slots just like we have on the current
intel mac pro so that's essentially
going to solve the issue of not having
enough ram with apple silicon and yes
imagineboo confirmed that the memory
team is working on a solution to fix it
because it is slower than the axis times
of the older xeon which basically
confirms that it is
slot in memory that they are using and
they're trying to connect it to apple
silicon and they're working on it right
now yes those are slots and in terms of
the actual graphics situation and how
apple is going to handle that hishnash
was telling me for a while that he
believes that the new apple silicon mac
pro is gonna continue to have lots of
pci express lots and i didn't believe
him until right now yes he says the mac
pro could ship with the m1 ultra first
and then m2 xtreme later providing a
bunch of mpx slots potentially with
apple's own gpus or even the old amd
gpus now in terms of what kind of
chassis apple apple's gonna use
based on all of this i think it totally
makes sense for apple to go the easiest
and the simplest route yes that means
literally taking the intel mac pro
and using the same chassis and the same
power supply the same fans everything
potentially just swapping out the cooler
for the cpu with a new copper cooler
that's better at cooling and literally
just switching out the motherboard with
a new apple silicon based motherboard
just like they did for the m1 mac mini
where they just changed up the
motherboard the logic board with the new
m1 chip i think they're gonna do the
same thing so it's gonna be the same
size on the back you're gonna have the
same memory slots and i do believe that
apple could actually keep the mpx
modules the same and to me this makes
the most sense because if apple is
trying to make as much profit as
possible it makes sense to continue
supporting amd graphics cards which for
a while now i was in denial i did not
think apple would do it but if they want
to make as much money as possible in the
easiest way they can continue supporting
those amd cards because they have a
really high markup on them and they can
continue selling massive amounts of ram
for extra money so the people who need a
lot of cpu power they're going to be
buying the really crazy quad chip which
is going to be very expensive like
thousands of dollars just for the quad
chip and then people who need even more
gpu power for like 3d rendering can buy
those mpx graphics modules and that
means that this new machine is going to
be extremely expensive basically just as
expensive as the old intel mac pro which
could go up to 50 000
it's probably gonna remain around the
same with the same profit margins for
apple
which is absolutely insane so with that
said we have all these leaks and rumors
pointing to wwdc for the new mac pro and
with hector martin saying that the m1
max quad die is now possible i think
that is the most likely scenario for
them to put that out first and then
later this year in the fall then they
can move on to the m2 with the new
redesigned macbook air so with that said
hopefully you enjoy this video and if
you did go ahead and click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one definitely check out one of
those two videos right there especially
the stacked chip one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]